HOST: On the afternoon
of July 23rd, 2019...
♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
...a 26 year-old LaToya Thompson
walked into a Red Lobster.
But she never quite made it to
those warm cheddar bay biscuits.
Is LaToya just missing?
Or was she murdered?
WOMAN: She told me her
and her boyfriend
was having problems.
I know he knows something.
Did he do it?
I didn't kill her though!
I mean, I killed (CENSORED).
(CHUCKLING)
Uh, you know, my condolences
to her moms and pops.
MAN: I knew something was up
when she came in the white boy.
Her "acting coach".
So, are you saying
she was having an affair?
I ain't no damn snitch.
HOST:
It's been almost two months
since LaToya went missing
and the cops
still have no leads.
We are doing everything
in our power to ensure
the safe return of this lost
Toyota.
This is the case about
Latoya Thompson,
not a missing vehicle.
No further comment at this time.
HOST:
This is Looking for LaToya.
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪